はっはーじゃあ根絶ら合わず安藤和津必要です皆さん amazon 使ってます
でしょうかまぁ僕も相当な回数 amazon 使ってるんですけどもあの問屋ですね
ほしい物リストっていう機能があるんですよ
ブログ dying どんなのかわかんないんでちょっと調べてみましょう欲しいもの
リスト等は amazon で買い戻す
時に今は買わないけどそのうちほしいなっていう商品をですね
他人にも公開できてしかもそれを買ってもらえるのか
だから母ツイッターでたまに見かけるんですけどもなんかプロフィールのところに
あなたの欲しいものリストって書いてある人がたまにいるんですけども
そういうことだったのねーほしい物リストに欲しい物帰っておくとひょっとしたら誰か
に買ってもらおう
あるかもしれないというのが欲しいものリストらしいのですよ悪人だ私もたまには人に
いいことしてるようじゃないかということで共同はアマゾンの全く知らないとの欲しい
ものリストのもの全部
突然肇社長が送りつけると切りやろうと思いますドッキリか分からんけどなぁもしです
よ
twitter とかで欲しいものにスト乗せてってとっておくれねし始めたつを全部
送られてくると
カビに見えると思うたまには人の役に立ってみようと思いますよ
パインでは早速誰の欲しいものリスト全部を送りつけるか探していこうと思います今回
の決勝だ遊戯アクションするかなんですよな方バカニックになってくれれば一番
美味しいですけど青なってみさんてくだかな
youtube でゲーム配信されている方なんですけどもフォローしてくれてますね
ありがとうございますあなたあ画像ほしいものリスト
no プロフィールに載せていますねちょっとしてみましょう失礼しますねはいを
チョコラ bb を欲しいんですね3 d クリスタルボウルた髪の恋0 k ちょい
釣り板ラミー果物屋さん
モバイルバッテリー充電ケーブル時パンクオリジナルスタイル t シャツ青めっちゃ
欲しいの多いなあショートブーツ
食べるパンツされるパンツ
[音楽]
多いな4妻
ちょっと多すぎライブっているのはこんな人がいますねおめでとうございます
amazon 祖先ものリストを発見しました失礼します
またやばいなダイソンのドライじゃあ欲しがってるなぁか自分で買いなさい
どちらか amazon ほしい物リストで検索していろんな人がユーザ出てきたん
ですけども
香らせしても問題ないかたところでしたいねこの1コスプレーヤーの方が居ますね
スプレーの玉木さん amazon ほしい物リスト失礼致します
忙しい人の作り右直度超簡単
レシピ世界上位4位手抜きごはん力尽きレシピ30
値段コシヒカリ10kg coming 柔軟剤ショップジャパンここ冷え
卓上冷風機おもしろ t シャツもやし
運命を感じてしまいました今回のプレゼントは
玉置さんに決まりましたおめでとうございますまた何を欲しがってんだろうとひじき t
シャツを欲しがっている
うどん t シャツバナナ t シャツアウトドアキャップコット折りたたみ式なら
色々星よってますねいいでしょ全部買ってあげましょうあのマジで本当に知らない人
です
マジで本当に知らないけど買ってあげますああ
いるハートに l 後にカートに入れるカートに入れる
なっている
カートやばいマジだよなんかすげー知らない人にはけどなんかちょっと何とも言えん
気持ちになるなーっていうカートに入れるカートに入れるか閉じるあカードでるんだ
カード入れるよね彼のゆるカートに入れるほぼ太郎電磁冷たいのねあの自分のピティ
モーターキプロスオリジナルサウンドトラック ok こんなもんでどうでしょうか
だあれ時に進みましょうこれねそれじゃあ13た
マッキーぐらいば c 方お届け先がすべて表示できませんこれで相手の住所がわから
ずとも僕がその人に多くれるっていう奴ですね
いただけます今すぐラッピングとができるんだパイラッピングしたのでここで枝葉爪
じゃないここで全部始めちゃったりしちゃえばいいんだろじゃあこれでもね結構わかん
ないけどうれしいと思うんですよね全部ラッピングしたけどめっちゃくちゃこの人に
激闘を楽しみ
ください肇社長が届くわけですよ欲しいものを知らない人がもらえるって普通に後な気
がするんですよ
[音楽]
排毒で準備完了しましたこれ知らない人の欲しいものリストの全商品を送る準備が整い
ました
スタっぽいぞこれ待って6番なぜ254円
馬まだ生まあ抑えた方じゃないでしょうか全然いい次長を送ってあげましょうそこで
注文確定すれば届くというわけですね
では
欲しい6リスト
全部くれてやるよ
を受けます
はい送らせていただきましたご覧くださいするでのお届先が玉記たまきたまきたまき
tamaki くさんあったこの全く知らないコスプレーヤーの玉木さんがどういう
反応してくれるのがとても楽しみでございますどういうリアクションするなど突然肇
社長に保守用の実は全部贈られる気持ちが知ってみたいですでは反応待ちましょう
はいおはようございますというわけで知らない人の欲しいものリストを全部購入して
から5時間くらいが経過しました ana get twitter とかどうなっ
てるんですけどちょっと見てみましょう
水通している
あ二時間前に終電逃しちゃったよか方はがて国高店シビ子が来たような
存分じゃ行くがよいとして40分前に数ノートが過ぎまだ気付いてないですね中でもさ
を送ってくれるとさ2児と行くんじゃないっていう関門何が贈られたことも知ってるの
かもしれないねちょっと終わったらないんですけど a 待って不安になってきた
胸の火
はぁっ
あいろいろで髪色が変わりました入ったけど欲しいものを一緒に書いてあったものを
全部送って二日間くらいが経ちました配送日度も見るともう結構物が付いてると思うん
で早速その人のツイッターがどういう反応をしているのか見ていこうと思います
はい次ちょっと売り越さとかやってるんですねえっ
パテが減ってる
今の家に住み始めてから浮き上がったなぁいやーすごいことあるモンスター
奇跡的だしたぞついつぶやいてるぞ amazon さん中小変更したはずなのになん
でか実家にギフトが届いたので帰ってきたんだけどまたまたなんでか肇社長の名前
できると送られてきとる
嬉しいけどご本人だろうそしてありがとう
でもどうして4
おめでとうございます当たったからです
信じられないんですね信じてくれてないっぽいぞこれでもうちょっと届いますねご覧
くださいちゃんとやっぱラッピングが貸してもらってますねあかんだフルラッピング
しばらく別のあるしちゃんとコシヒカリも覚えてますそしてご覧くださいギフトをお
楽しみください
はじめしゃちょーよくあった zard 穂井田よかったよかった
遊んだけっぽいですね
ええっ
や様が手でもなんかすごい喜んでくれてますねこの人実家にゲストが届いちゃったっ
ぽいんだよねそれとって帰ってきた感じっぽいように見えますややっぱりも信じられ
にくいですね
何か欲しいものリストにものを送るとそのニックネームとか自分の穴等で特区面でもの
を送ることができるね肇社長って書いて送っても肇社長って信じられないかもしれない
けど
わかりましたでも嬉しいって言ってくれてる良かったですね誰か知りませんが玉置さん
ありがとうございます
ん
でも他の人に送っても信じられないようだからねだトークいませんんん
[音楽]
car
ん
bel
el mejor
me